[Música]
hola a todos soy vana y si me
retrotraigo a mi infancia cuando vivían
entrerríos la mayoría de los chicos de
mi barrio eran varones así que las dos
únicas mujeres no nos quedó más remedio
que adaptarnos a los juegos de ellos de
esa manera me convertí en una activa
jugadora de fútbol a pesar de no tener
ninguna de las dotes deportivas para
ello y para grandes gracias del equipo
en donde me tocaba jugar
todo esto sin dejar de jugar a las
muñecas con la maestra después en la
adolescencia tuve la inquietud de
estudiar otros idiomas más allá del
tradicional inglés y encare con el
alemán y además era la exótica a la que
le gustaba ir a conciertos de música
clásica o de jazz de nuevo todo esto sin
dejar de hacer las típicas salidas
adolescentes con amigos
y un día se pusieron de moda las
polleras largas una de mis mejores
amigas me dijo nosotros somos muy
bajitas no podemos usar cocheras largas
no podemos usar polleras largas pensé y
esto quiere decir que no tengo ni 20
años y por el resto de mi vida nunca me
voy a poder poner una pollera larga como
puede ser que lo dispuso porque ese
parámetro porque el límite
creo que siempre estuvo dentro de mí la
semillita de ir más allá no se trataba
de no compartir los cánones típicos de
la edad o de quienes me rodeaban sino de
ampliarlos de no tener que elegir una
sola opción
de cuestionar cada tanto los estándares
y el status quo
continué mi camino y está terminando la
facultad en la universidad nacional del
litoral en santa fe tuve la inquietud de
hacer una pasantía tenía ganas de
hacerlo en una empresa que tuviera
diferentes áreas y procesos
y lo que estaba disponible más
interesante no estaba en la ciudad sino
40 kilómetros en franck y había que
empezar a trabajar a las 7 de la mañana
horario que definitivamente no es mi
preferido
pasado el proceso de selección empecé a
trabajar allí
la rutina cotidiana era bastante
incómoda tenía que levantarme a las
cinco y cuarto de la mañana y me tomaba
un colectivo un poco desarmado que no
tenía aire acondicionado ni calefacción
y adónde a veces se nos engancha va la
ropa
y sumado esto lo tenía que combinar con
las últimas materias de la facultad
definitivamente no era cómodo
porque el cambio salir del límite de la
zona de confort buscar nuevos horizontes
nos lleva a lo desconocido a lo
diferente nos trae incertidumbre
inseguridad el cambio incómoda nos
obliga a adaptarnos y a ser flexibles
pero a la vez nos llena de
satisfacciones porque nos lleva a nuevos
logros
nos permite ver que ahora somos más
amplios que nuestro mundo se expandió
que construimos que compartimos con
otros conocimos nuevas personas que nos
traen otras perspectivas y miradas y de
quiénes podemos aprender el cambio en
definitiva nos lleva a disfrutar nuevos
caminos
mientras estaba haciendo esta primera
experiencia laboral me recibí en la
facultad tuve una beca de iniciación a
la docencia aquí mismo
fui ayudante de cartera en distintas
materias y seguí con los idiomas inglés
alemán y ahora también francés
y entonces 40 km ya no me parecieron muy
lejos porque en una experiencia
internacional
pensé en la posibilidad de alguna
universidad que no fuera costosa y que
me permitiera el desafío de otro idioma
y así emprendió el camino a la
universidad de passau en baviera
alemania
pasado es una ciudad universitaria que
está ahora a orilla de tres ríos uno de
ellos el famoso danubio
si bien esto era el sueño de mi vida
hecho realidad no fue tan sencillo
recuerdo el día en que ingresé en la
habitación de la residencia
universitaria
de pasado y después de pasada la euforia
inicial me senté en la cama y me largué
a llorar pensando que hice es una locura
dejé mi familia amigos mi trabajo mi
país para venir a este pueblo de nuevo
la incertidumbre y la incomodidad
pero por suerte la pena no me duró
demasiado y ese mismo día hice un tour
por la universidad con otros estudiantes
extranjeros y ahí conocí a una sueca que
fue mi amiga y compañera de aventuras de
aquella época y me entusiasmé con más
idiomas inglés alemán y francés y ahora
también un poco de italiano y con viajar
siempre conmigo licita a cuestas de
nuevo ir más allá ampliar mi mundo
y entonces busque nuevos desafíos quería
hacer una pasantía en una empresa
alemana
así como me dirigí a múnich y empecé a
trabajar en la casa matriz de una
empresa automotriz alemana a donde
continúa aún hoy 20 años después
para sumar una rareza yo era una
santafesina en múnich y conocí a un
salteño en múnich que con los años se
convirtió en mi marido
otra vez no todo fue tan sencillo por
razones laborales a lo largo de cuatro
años durante nuestro noviazgo tuvimos
que estar en dos continentes separados
el en argentina y yo todavía en europa
así que en épocas en que internet no era
tan fluido ni las redes sociales
existían se nos ocurrían locuras como
ponernos la misma película
simultáneamente en dos continentes
distintos mirarla y después amarnos por
teléfono para comentarla y así el camino
se fue poniendo cada vez más divertido
combinando desafíos y logros
y después de cinco años en alemania la
empresa me ofreció ir a trabajar a la
filial española con sede en madrid
esto era otra cosa que no era tan común
y se fue sumando algunos de estos puntos
no típicos que había tenido en mi vida
ser una nena que jugaba el fútbol en
épocas en que lo hacían sólo los varones
esto por suerte ahora cambio que
estudiaba alemán a la que le gustaba el
jazz que se empecinaba en ponerse
polleras largas a pesar de medir sólo un
metro y medio que conocía un salteño en
múnich o que empezaba a trabajar en una
empresa internacional no en su
subsidiaria local sino en su casa matriz
pero eso nunca me sentí una transgresora
del límite
siempre lo que me movilizó fueron las
ganas de hacer de emprender de vivir de
viajar y sobre todo de aprovechar todas
las oportunidades sin importar si venían
en un colectivo sin aire acondicionado o
en un confortable auto alemán
y siete años después de esta venta haber
iniciado esta aventura europea
regrese a argentina y ocupe de
diferentes funciones en la filial local
de la empresa alemana
cualquier función en argentina es poco
convencional para los estrictos
parámetros corporativos alemanes pero
una de las que me tocó en particular
entre varias fue la menos convencional
de todas ser gerente de exportación en
una empresa que había sido creada
exclusivamente para importar
y además una función que no existía en
ninguna parte del mundo pero bueno es lo
que tocaba había que adaptarse así que
creamos los procesos y el negocio para
poder desempeñar la función
y después si llegó el gran dilema
familia o trabajo porque no ambos
después de ir paso a paso desarrollando
mi carrera laboral lo más importante fue
que forme una familia
la santafesina y el salteño tuvieron
tres hijos fácil de ningún modo como
muchos de ustedes saben es complejo y
hermoso
es agotador y revitalizante y también se
logra sólo con mucho apoyo familiar
porque ningún límite se traspone solo
sin la ayuda de otros
y acá me encuentro hoy tratando de ser
una madre presente que cuenta cuentos e
inventa canciones juega cocina con sus
hijos y a la vez desarrolla su trabajo o
trata de desarrollarlo con compromisos
con dedicación y con responsabilidad y
entre todo esto tratando de disfrutar y
de divertirme a pesar de que con todos
estos malabares obviamente no todo salga
perfecto
después de más de 20 años que llevo de
trayectoria en finanzas de nuevo el
límite y la corrección corporativa
indicaban que debía seguir así en el
ámbito de las finanzas pero hace poco
tiempo surgió una nueva oportunidad
la de tener una función más amplia que
también tuviera un componente más
importante comercial sencillo o de la
filial local de la empresa alemana una
mujer al frente de una automotriz
otra vez por qué no
y acá me encuentro hoy
mirando el espejo retrovisor mientras
intento también proyectar me hace el
camino que tengo por delante poniendo un
renovado foco en la comunicación la
motivación en tratar de generar el
trabajo en conjunto no tengo todas las
respuestas
simplemente trato de ir disfrutando el
camino con los que me rodean con quienes
enfrentamos cada desafío cotidiano y
hubo muchos desafíos y muchas
dificultades
ir más allá de una frontera aparente no
se trata de desafiar al sistema ni de
una transgresión sino simplemente de no
limitarse a la hora de tener ganas de
hacer algo de alcanzar un objetivo de
vivir una experiencia
el motor no es romper el límite sino
preguntarse por qué no
no poner el foco en el límite sino en el
horizonte en aquello que queremos
alcanzar que tenemos ganas de hacer y
apreciar el camino por más que haya
momentos muy difíciles en que parezca
que no vamos a llegar y muchas veces la
meta apareció inalcanzable
pero sin importar si el camino es largo
o corto
difícil o sencillo el inicio para llegar
a la meta es siempre el mismo dar el
primer paso
en este camino
muchos me hicieron crecer y traté de
ayudar a otros a crecer especialmente
los que menos creían en ellos mismos no
importa si el desafío es grande o es
chico y si el camino es el convencional
o uno que elijamos nosotros siempre vale
la pena intentarlo
hoy comparto con ustedes un pedacito de
mi historia estoy segura que la de todos
ustedes tiene mucho de todo esto también
por eso es que los invito a que nos
preguntemos juntos qué pasó vamos a dar
hoy que nueva experiencia
vamos a disfrutar qué aventura nos vamos
a proponer encarar para que el mundo o
nuestro entorno sea un lugar mejor para
ayudar a otro o simplemente para tratar
de ser un poco más felices y disfrutar
para mí
el motor para ir más allá del límite no
es desafiar al otro sino desafiarnos a
nosotros mismos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah